how are all of you doing
it's a 20-18 which means it's a little
bit slow in the video game release
calendar it gives us time to think about
some events that we've been to in the
past and maybe talk about them a little
bit more one of those that keeps coming
up in our conversations is a preview
event we went to for far cry 5 and some
of the things that we didn't talk about
the first time around
so we wanted to take the chance to
highlight six more things that we
noticed that you should probably know
about far cry 5
joining me is editor miguel concepción
hi all right so let's get to the first
point which is the biggest change in
this game the thing that's missing
towers yes indeed towers are gone those
were a very important component in far
cry 4 in fact I had a little bit of a
refresher it was interesting the
flexibility in ways you could take on
towers I was particularly fond of and
I'm gonna miss being able to like get
into a gyrocopter and fly directly to
the top of a tower whether I just jump
out and wings suited or if I just manage
to like land the gyrocopter on the tower
now you're gonna be other ways for you
to like reveal the map we suspect it's
gonna involve taking over these cultists
outposts yeah it looks like it's more of
a classic fog of war situation now where
you just talk to people you it's or
organically and naturally let's not say
the elements of towers are gone in this
game there's still a few left that are
kind of a nod and a wink but they don't
reveal things around them but now
there's prepper stashes which go down
into the ground instead of up into the
sky and feature some of the puzzles and
difficulty that you would have
traditionally found in those towers
they're also a place where you will have
story exposition and pick up things like
perks so we're curious to see how a Far
Cry 5 will feel without just the show
you everything around you you can do
mechanic that previous games have had
[Music]
so the second thing that we want to talk
about is the fact that this game is
fully playable and co-op so in the last
one you could do side missions but this
whole thing can be done as campaign with
friends for hire and the experience of
playing with somebody else being we know
with all the similarities previous Fargo
games potentially one of the biggest
changes or the biggest draws to Far Cry
5 I could really see the game sort of
catering to different co-op makeups
whether it's like two snipers or two
guys who are just armed to the teeth and
are just you know charging into outposts
I'm more curious about its like how
whether or not the game like ramps up or
adjust in difficulty based on whether or
not you go solo or co-op you and I flew
into a equivalent of a heavy base in an
airplane and then wings suited down one
of us went for a tower the other person
went for a dangerous mortar tube at the
back of the base and that was a huge
problem but that's not to say that later
on when you start to unlock things
somebody couldn't just bomb from the air
you can have somebody in an airplane
potentially bombing the baseball the
other person's on the ground knifing
people there's a lot of potential for
ways to tackle missions in that sandbox
way that you could only do with side
missions in the previous firefight I
think they're they're counting on fans
who'd be surprised even through failure
and they hopefully will be interested in
just like retrying certain outpost
invasions multiple times and trying to
get it right that's a very good point in
that ties into the third thing that we
want to talk about which was changes in
henchmen so you had some pretty strong
opinions about henchmen and where they
are right now in the game versus
previous Far Cry titles from my vibe
they seemed a lot more aggressive in
terms of like encountering them on the
road I mean we encode this as far back
as far cry 3 where they would just pass
by you if you drove fast enough you
won't have to worry about any
engagements but I got the vibe that
these enemies in Far Cry 5 are gonna be
they might have an opportunity to like
deal some damage and you're gonna end up
like using one of your health packs
because right as you're just driving by
right in terms of the actual or in terms
of the actual missions you did bring up
a good point that
some of these cultists who are not
wearing any armor seem to be very they
seem to be quite the bullet sponges and
I you make an interesting sort of
justification that they just might be
like hopped up on painkillers
[Music]
so the fourth thing in one of the larger
changes that I noticed was a lot more I
don't know if I can call it
customization yet because we don't know
how much you can tweak vehicles in
planes but there's a huge variety of
vehicles planes choppers cars boats ATVs
tractors and there's checkpoints all
over the map air strips helicopter hood
pads and throughout the game you can
earn and unlock crazy versions of these
so you wrote around and one called the
Deathwish car how'd you feel about the
variety vehicles and the crazy versions
of those vehicles I'm guessing that
Ubisoft mindset is just giving players
the the flexibility and sort of choice
of personal preference I don't think
that it's a case of like trying to make
one car more a one more vehicle and more
attractive than the other based on stats
I think they're counting on fans to be
drawn in by the different service like
styles and aesthetics that's that's the
vibe I've gotten so far I got the car by
completing a stunt mission there's a
very strong optional racing component
and previous Far Cry games have had this
this one's more sort of sensational
because it's sort of an Evel Knievel's
inspired you have to recreate these
races that this mythical daredevil from
the 70s that you have to redo you have
to like drive the same routes that he
did I think it's really nice that this
games gonna have a ton of vehicles and
the fact that it seems like you're gonna
be able to have access to a lot of them
based on just like how much you could
afford and be able to call them in in
the right places I think it's gonna be
it's gonna be it's just gonna give the
player a lot of options without nerfing
the overall experience so the fifth
thing that we noticed and this was a not
very change from the previous farcry was
animal attacks I didn't see any face
eating Eagles but there were plenty of
crazy insane animals there were farm
animals this time around there were we
saw like bears fighting farm animals
that felt missing to me and other Ruby
soft games after after I played Far Cry
titles I love those immersion
experiences where you're about to do
something and a bear runs out of the
and starts just mauling everybody and
screwing your plans up right that's very
true and the fact that I emerged from a
forest and found this bull taking on
this bear it sort of just kind of lent
some character to the overall world that
is basically showing me that all these
things are happening regardless of your
involvement so I'm excited about that
I'm glad that there are also still
opportunities to free wild animals from
their cages and enemy outposts so I'm
hoping to use that strategically I will
say it's gonna be hard for them to
compete with far cry 4 there was so much
personality in riding elephants you know
random Eagle attacks Jaguars some of
that is here we didn't I didn't see any
animals that you could ride like the
elephants actually another good point is
the skinning animation wasn't in the
game I don't know if it wasn't there yet
in the build that we saw or you're just
not gonna skin animals anymore when you
go up to them you can still pull meat
off of them but when we went through the
upgrade tree it looked like you just
bought things again it was a work in
progress when we saw it right I mean Far
Cry 3 even as far back as far cry 3
sometimes I would not I would take a
break from story missions because I
wanted to focus on not having to worry
about my loot capacity so I would go and
open up other areas just so I could find
this particular animal that would yield
a bigger loot sack and the sixth thing
that we wanted to talk about was and
it's kind of an unavoidable conversation
but the Ubisoft thing right the
similarities to other airsoft games
particularly seeing elements of Ghost
Recon wildlands you walk around and you
see stuff that you would see in the
cartel zones like hanging dead bodies in
the landscape and even a helicopter
puzzle ready to shoot henchmen in a
certain order to steal it I mean I see
these comparisons particularly with wild
lines as a positive I mean obviously
this game was in development before the
release of wild lands but wild lands
became one of those successes of 2017
it's developed this really huge
following I mean things like a lot of
air traversal kind of made me think
about wild lands a lot also the
progression towards the the final boss
and having to take out some of
the family members reminded me of the
path to the main boss and wildlands
though I suspect it might actually even
be maybe like a more concise path in Far
Cry 5 and it just speaks overall - I
mean Ubisoft just I mean playing to
their strengths
they've in the past decade they have
evolved into sort of the the quote
unquote open-world studio and it I think
it's worked out for them mostly and
positive so those were six more things
you should know about far cry 5 are you
seeing big enough differences do you
just love that thing the Far Cry does in
general are you sort of burned out on
the Ubisoft open-world formula give us
your thoughts in the comments below and
we'll talk about tomorrow
make sure to stay tuned to games because
we're expecting to see more of this game
in the future and the longwood Far Cry
five we've got Mel Gear survived at
Monster Hunter World on the horizon so
we can't wait to talk about those games
with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]